[Musique]
qui n'a pas souvenir d'un bon croise à
cette gâterie feuilleter dont les
saveurs de beurre explosent en bouche
moi chaque fois ça me rappelle quand
j'étais petit et qu'on allait à la
boulangerie mais les croissants quand on
en a acheté passe et et oui c'était jour
de fête
et quand on aime le beurre on ne peut
que l'aimer le croissant donc
donc moi j'aime le beurre j'aime les
croissances benoît thibault fait partie
de ces artisans qui excelle dans l'art
du croissant un bon croissance est avant
tout un croissant croustillant c'est un
croissant qui va être gras mais pas en
excès est ce un croissant qui doivent
goûter le beurre
[Applaudissements]
benoît en a fait des milliers chacun
soigneusement roulé à la main et cuit à
la perfection mais les croissants vendus
en épicerie peuvent-ils être aussi
réussi que ceux des artisans l'épicerie
a fait le tour des grandes surfaces et
on a trouvé une vingtaine que nous avons
soumis à deux experts en boulangerie
déjà il faut commencer avec des bons
ingrédients farine beurre secret au
voilà ce que ça prend pour faire un bon
croissant selon marie pascale bonne
enseignante et mario fortin consultant
en boulangerie ça demeure quand même le
produit pour moi en boulangerie le plus
complexes à fabriquer parce que beaucoup
d'étapes dont on parle
mélanger la pâte à personne incorporer
du beurre ou de margarine pour faire le
tour âge donc d'être capable de plier la
pâte à pour se retrouver avec une couche
de pâte une couche de beurre une couche
de pâte donc c'est cette succession de
couches de pâques qui va faire qu'on va
avoir un produit qui va être bien
développé
c'est ce tour âge ou repli de la pâte
sur elle-même qui va donner le fameux
feuilletage au croissant il faut savoir
contrôler la fermentation donc la
fameuse pouces et puis on va finir avec
la cuisson donc un produit bien cuit
pour une meilleure conservation pour une
meilleur match qu'un produit qui n'est
pas assez cuit ne reporte du rugby
le gros des ti ça va être ça c'est de
recréer le croissant artisanale mais de
manière industrielle
[Musique]
nous avons d'abord soumis à nos experts
si croissant parmi les moins chers de
mai très gentils en âge soit ceux à la
margarine déjà deuil est ce que vous
voyez des évidences sommes engagés se
démarque en étant toujours un peu plus
porte trois chambres
c'est que c'est cuit d'un défaut qui
sont pas assez chaud donc on perd aussi
le feuilletage moi je vois qu'une
absence de feuilletage ont la plupart
des produits comparativement un
croissance sont tous très très lisse à
vous l'honneur
peu de différences entre les croissants
de cette catégorie
moi je vois pas de différence je ne sens
pas de différences nos plus belles
trouve qu'ils goûtent mieux que le goût
est meilleur que ce qui paraît assez sûr
que la marche est assez long faut quand
même assez longtemps je trouve avant de
l'avaler c'est sûr que c'est pas un
produit qui qui fond dans la bouche mais
là on est dans de la margarine donc
c'est normal
et pour moi c'est un croissant brioché
on voit dessus des larmes à la barre ce
qui était fait et et on veut rappeler
demi est intacte voilà me intérieur qui
est beaucoup plus une mitraille de son
voeu donc j'aime ça j'appelle bio chez
parce que c'est plus chic et quand même
pas comme quoi une brioche
[Musique]
bridor géant mondial du croissant en
prêt par des dizaines de milliers à ses
usines de montréal et les propos sous
différentes marques
ces croissances ont tous y expédie
partout en amérique du nord et sont
parmi les moins chers pour moi une
petite odeur qui meurent qui me dérange
je voudrais regarder les ingrédients
tous ses croissants contiennent de
l'huile de palme modifier ou hydrogénées
et des additifs dont des enzymes des
enzymes alimentaire c'est quoi on
retrouve du moelleux dans un produit
c'est les enzymes
mais ces engins et agissent sur jour 5
et plus donc des fois défendre l'âge est
un produit au zoo sans gants dit me
semble que de la plus frais qu'au début
ce sont les limites
même les croissants congelés ont fait
partie de notre dégustation
pour moi ça la pâte feuilletée plus tôt
c'est plus ça qu'on a encore une fois
kwassa brioché et ça manque un peu de
couleurs toujours sonné ça passe pas
mais aux bouches pensait plus des succès
certains contiennent des arômes naturels
ya la saveur demeure que moi
personnellement je je n'apprécie pas
encore un petit peu de temps pour moi
c'est ce que je suis pas habitué à
manger des croissants à la margarine
mais malgré tout je suis un jeu surprise
jura quelques-uns que je serai capable
comme on disait de manger un sandwich
sans problème
sans surprise nos experts ont préféré
les croissants au beurre
même si la cuisson de certains étaient
insuffisantes
déjà la manche est meilleur que legault
de dollars soit mauvais mais j'ai pas
l'impression de manger un croissant
rassemble plusieurs croissance se
ressemblait beaucoup au niveau de la vie
des ingrédients c'est exactement les
mêmes ingrédients
la plupart des produits vendus en
épicerie sont fabriqués en usine
mais quelques uns sont livrées congelées
en épicerie est cuit sur place
c'est le cas des croissants de première
moisson c'est un produit sans agents de
conservation donc un produit qui ne peut
pas être sur les tablettes pour long
très longtemps donc cesser de le faire à
la mesure c'est plus plus facile pour
les épiciers de contrôle et que ça prend
vraiment de la formation quand même des
gens qui sont assez expérimentés qui ont
l'oeil pour savoir le moment idéal de
passer à la cuisson je crois que tous
les fabricants industriels font de très
très bons produits
sauve qui est détériorée souvent par
l'épicier qui le fuit mal donc les
croissance s'affaissent parce qu'ils ne
sont pas cuits à l'intérieur indécis
croissant cuit sur place avec une belle
couleur mais un arrière-goût
il ya quelque chose qui me chicote une
odeur assez aigre mais d autres
croissant cuit sur place ont séduit nos
experts il est encore un peu croquant
les lébous était encore conscient
puis au bourg est bon au final ce sont
les deux produits vendu congelé que l'on
cuit à la maison qui se sont démarqués
bombe et là ça s'arrange eu les doigts
qui sans gras donc c'est bon signe mais
faut pas qu'ils soient trop gras non
plus au niveau du nez ça commence à
sentir le beurre le premier un produit
qui est directement du congélateur au
four très très beau développement
le soufflé est croustillant l'extérieur
faute d'avoir un croissant artisanal
tout droit sorti du four nos experts
suggèrent de toujours réchauffer vos
croissante d'épicerie avant de les
manger
[Musique]